Speaker 1: Let's go next. There's a lot of people
wanting to get on today. Very interesting, folks.
Oh, let's go to our friend Scott from Pensacola,
who we've spoken before, right, Scott?
Scott, from Pensacola, you're on
the air if you unmute yourself.
Speaker 3: Oh, boy. You got me. Yes, now you're
on. All right. So the question I've got today is.
What do you think of the general public and kind
of do as far as people that are concerned with
the way things are going with some
of these school board meetings
and the potential for violence with some of them?
Speaker 1: Oof, it's so tough because saying that
the answer is to show up to counter the
wacky school board people is only likely
to trigger them more and maybe even likely to
cause violence in and of itself because these
people are so volatile. So it's very tough to say.
I mean, I one idea that's been suggested is that
there is a temporary hiatus of public comment at
school board meetings, but my instinct is never
to suppress speech. And I don't know about you,
Scott, but my instinct is that that's not how I
want to fix a problem. So it's very, very tough.
I mean, maybe there need to be more strictly
enforced rules of decorum at these school board
meetings? I don't know, but it's become a mess.
Speaker 3: I definitely agree with
you, I think that if we were to
limit speech at those sorts of things,
it could end up with a slippery slope
and some unintended consequences.
Speaker 1: I mean, I think that
one thing maybe is that the people who act out
like children at the there are adults legally,
but they act like children. They really should
be shamed and humiliated in their communities.
I mean, my instinct is that sometimes people go up
like a remote. We played a video of a girl and her
dad, who both quoted Hitler in their opposition
to masks, and people in the crowd cheered. And
so if those folks were ostracized and humiliated
in their communities, my guess is they'd be less
likely to do this stuff. But they're not going
to be ostracized and humiliated when half the
community seems to agree with them, you know?
Speaker 3: And then they'll just cry cancel
culture if that happens anyway. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Speaker 1: No, it's a tough question,
but it's wacky. What's going on?
All right. Thanks for your time,
David. Hey, listen, before you go,
is the Gulf Breeze Pensacola Bridge
finally reopened or what's going on down there?
Speaker 3: So the Gulf Breeze Pensacola Bridge is
open for two lanes in each direction. So for
those who don't know, during Hurricane Sally, some
barges that were used by the construction company
got loose and damaged the bridge and it was shut
down and everybody had to take a toll road around
and it really ruined traffic around here for about
nine months. Yeah, I mean, didn't it make it
Speaker 1: didn't make what can be a 15
minute trip, like a 75 minute trip by
having to drive all the way around?
Speaker 3: Yeah. If you had to go all the way
around, yes. To get to downtown Pensacola,
there were a lot of businesses that suffered
on both sides of the bridge. So hopefully.
The litigation that's involved with
that will will make some things right.
Speaker 1: Yeah, yeah, we have friends down
there who live in Gulf Breeze and work in
downtown Pensacola, and it was just a complete
and total mess. I kind of liked Pensacola. I
have to tell you, I know it's like it is sort of
the deep south. It's not Miami Beach, you know?
But I actually had a good time. The food scene
wasn't bad. There's some place called like the
is it the something grill downtown met
its blue something? Does that ring a bell?
Speaker 3: Not off the top of my head, my
favorite restaurants are going to be the
grand marlin out on Pensacola Beach
Speaker 1: AU Grand Marlin. Yeah,
there is, you know where I went when
I was there, I went to Joe Patty's.
Speaker 3: Oh, nice, yeah.
Speaker 1: Got some great crab
Speaker 3: legs you can get?
Speaker 1: Yeah, yeah,
absolutely. Anyway, hope to make it down there
again. Glad to hear the bridges reopened.
All right, thanks, David. OK, very good.
There we go there, Scott from Pensacola,
working with a little bit of a delay, but
we did the absolute best we could with it.
You can only do so much with it.
You know, that's that's the reality.